le bois de saraguay d'un quartier vélo
l'endroit de toute beauté mais méconnu
du public puisse la raison en est fort
simple c'est que l'ancienne forêt la
plus ancienne forêt de l'élan fait et
clôturé depuis des décennies en 2011 la
ville de montréal important voter un
budget pour l'aménagement mais après
trois ans rien n'a encore été fait comme
nous dit michel marcelet voici à quoi
ressemblait montréal autant de la
nouvelle france nous voici reggae est un
vestige de l'ancienne forêt qui couvrait
toute l'île on parle de plus de 90
hectares de forêt on observe une
biodiversité est en assez phénoménal
juste dans ce petit boisé là alors dans
une seule excursion ont pu observer
jusqu'à 60 espèces végétales et près de
30 espèces animales facilement sauver
des promoteurs immobiliers par des
groupes citoyens à la fin des années 70
le bois de saraguay a d'abord obtenu
l'appellation parc nature puis plus rien
l'endroit est aux tueries presque
inaccessible je suis leduc gauvin milite
depuis des années pour sa mise en valeur
quand on a commencé c'est comme si on
parlait de la planète marche c'est à
tomber dans l'oubli c'est un endroit
extraordinaire
c'est tellement beau encore aujourd'hui
après 35 ans quand j'entre ici je me
sens comme alice au pays des merveilles
des travaux d'aménagement devait débuter
en 2012 délais après délais on les
attend toujours
c'est inacceptable aussi après toutes
ces années qu'on attend depuis 35 ans
dans le fond réal ménard responsable des
parcs à montréal rappelle que la ville
n'est pas seul dossier ce boisé là est
protégée selon les lois de l'assemblée
nationale
c'est un des grâces est patrimoniaux du
québec même statut que le rocher percé
en gaspésie
le fédéral s'en mêlent également puisque
une loi protégeant les oiseaux empêche
de faire des travaux dans la forêt six
mois par année
le projet serait toutefois sur le point
d'aboutir pour moi c'est une priorité
alors il ya deux points 9 millions $
sont réservés et discussion se poursuit
cette semaine sur l'aménagement du bois
de saraguay mais pour l'instant les
travaux ne débuteront qu'à l'automne
ici monsieur marsolais radio canada
montréal